>> Laura: THANKS A LOT.
WELCOME TO "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
FROM WASHINGTON.
IT'S TOO COLD ON THE ROOF FOR
ME.
CAN STOP THE BLEEDING.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT
ANGLE.
THINK ABOUT HOW REPORTERS WOULD
HANDLE THINGS UNDER THIS
HYPOTHETICAL.
HILLARY CLINTON, NOT
I REALIZE THAT'S TERRIFYING TO
CONTEMPLATE, BUT BEAR WITH ME
FOR JUST A SECOND.
IMAGINE THAT BILL IS TOO OLD TO
CHASE INTERN SO SHE ISN'T
DISTRACTED BY ANY NEW SCANDALS,
AND SOMEHOW DURING HER FIRST
YEAR IN OFFICE, HILLARY OVERSEES
A STOCK MARKET ROCKETING UP,
THERE'S A BIG DROP IN
UNEMPLOYMENT, INCLUDING AMONG
MINORITY WORKERS, AND IMAGINE
THIS, IMAGINE CONSUMER
CONFIDENCE, BUSINESS INVESTMENT,
EVEN WAGES IN CERTAIN SECTORS,
ALL UP.
IMAGINE HILLARY ANNOUNCING THAT
DOZENS OF AMERICAN RUN
BUSINESSES ARE BRINGING JOBS
BACK TO THE UNITED STATES.
THEY ARE DOLING OUT THOUSAND
DOLLARS, $2,000 BONUSES TO
REPUBLICAN LEADERS RESPOND TO
GIMMICK.
UNILATERAL ACTION TO LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD FOR AMERICAN
MANUFACTURERS AND WORKERS.
BY THE WAY, I ACTUALLY REMEMBER
WHEN BOTH HILLARY AND
BARACK OBAMA WERE RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT IN 2008 AND BACK THEN
THEY BOTH SOUNDED A LOT MORE
LIKE TRUMP THAN TRUDEAU ON
NAFTA.
>> NAFTA IS GONE IN SIX MONTHS.
>> WE WILL OPT OUT OF NAFTA
UNLESS WE RENEGOTIATED.
>> I THINK SENATOR CLINTON'S
ANSWER ON THIS ONE IS RIGHT.
IF I THINK WE SHOULD USE THE
HAMMER OF POTENTIAL OPT OUT.
>> Laura: DOES ANYONE EVEN
REMEMBER THAT?
I DO.
IMAGINE HILLARY CLINTON
TARGETING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
TERMINALS, FELONS, WHO ARE
ENDANGERING THEIR MOSTLY
HISPANIC NEIGHBORHOODS.
IMAGINE IF, THANKS TO THE
MILITARY PLANNING UNDER
COMMANDER IN CHIEF CLINTON WE
HAD SMASHED ISIS AND DRIVEN THEM
OUT OF SYRIA.
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
DECLINE OF THE AMERICAN MIDDLE
CLASS.
>> REPUBLICANS NEED TO LOOK IN
THE MIRROR, THINK ABOUT THE
DAMAGE THAT THEY ARE CAUSING TO
THE MIDDLE CLASS, OUR ECONOMY.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP CONSISTENTLY
POINTS TO ONE HIGHLIGHT, A
STRONG ECONOMY.
IT WAS A GOOD YEAR, BUT MAYBE
NOT AS GOOD AS PRESIDENT TRUMP
WANTS YOU TO THINK.
>> Laura: CHUCK, AMAZING.
NOT THAT LIBERALS CARE.
THEY NOT ONLY DON'T GIVE TRUMP
CREDIT FOR HIS POLICIES OR ANY
REWORK TO TRAIN DEALERS OR MOVES
ON REAL ADULATION, THERE ARE
ACTUALLY SOME EVEN TRYING TO
GIVE OBAMA CREDIT FOR ALL OF
2017s GOOD ECONOMIC NEWS.
>> HE THINKS IT STARTED FROM THE
DAY HE BECAME PRESIDENT WHEN IN
IT BACK FROM THE PRECIPICE WITH
TOUGH ACTION.
>> MR. TRUMP INHERITED AN
ECONOMY THAT WAS IN FULL
RECOVERY FOR BLACKS AND WHITES
FROM PRESIDENT OBAMA.
NOW HE'S TAKING CREDIT FOR
PICKING UP SOMEBODY AT THE END
>> Laura: SOMEBODY ELSE DROVE
THE TRIP.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT HE'S
TALKING ABOUT.
TO ADD INSULT TO INJURY, EVEN
WHILE BUSINESS LEADERS DO CREDIT
TRUMP'S TAX CUT WITH ALL THE
DEREGULATION, WHAT'S THE BIG
BUSINESS STORY OF TODAY?
HERE IT IS.
A NEW REUTERS POLL CLAIMING THAT
JUST 2% OF AMERICANS HAVE GOTTEN
A RAISE, A BONUS OR OTHER
BENEFITS FROM TRUMP'S TAX CUTS.
OKAY, KIDS, HERE'S A LESSON FROM
LAURA.
YOU USUALLY GET A BENEFIT FROM A
TAX CUT WHEN YOU PAY YOUR TAXES.
EVERYONE IS GOING TO BENEFIT
EXCEPT FOR UPPER INCOME EARNERS.
HELLO?
AND FROM THE TRUMP TAX PLAN,
THEY WILL SEE MORE MONEY IN
THEIR POCKETS COME APRIL WHEN
MOST PEOPLE PAY THEIR TAXES.
MOST PEOPLE DON'T PAY QUARTERLY.
WE WILL SEE IF AT THAT POINT
REUTERS RUNS ANOTHER POLL JUST
TO SEE IF PEOPLE ARE HAPPIER OR
BENEFITING.
A FAR MORE TELLING SURVEY FROM
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
BUSINESS ECONOMICS FINDS THAT
COMPANY SAY SALES AND PROFITS
ROSE AT THE END OF LAST YEAR AND
NEARLY HALF OF THE RESPONDENTS
SAY THEY ARE NOW PAYING MORE IN
WAGES AND IN SALARIES TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES.
THIS IS NEWS THAT WE'VE BEEN
WAITING FOR AND THAT WILL
BENEFIT WORKERS LONG TERM.
IT'S ABOUT TIME PEOPLE HAD A
RAISE.
I PROMISE YOU, IF
HILLARY CLINTON HAD HAD THIS
RECORD, THE PRAISE WOULD BE
DEAFENING ON THE EVE OF HER
DAY BLAMING THE REAL PRESIDENT
McCABE.
>> THE PRESIDENT PLAY THIS VERY
ACTIVE, PUBLIC ROLE IN
PRESSURING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO GET RID OF
McCABE.
>> SO FAR THE WHITE HOUSE IS
SAYING THE PRESIDENT WAS NOT
INVOLVED IN THIS, WAS NOT PUSHED
AT ALL.
IT SEEMS HARD TO BELIEVE THAT.
>> THIS IS YET ANOTHER INSTANCE
OF THE PRESIDENT BULLYING AND
PRESSURING LAW ENFORCEMENT
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT --
>> Laura: MEDIA BIAS AT NBC,
THAT'S MY QUESTION.
THE ONLY PROBLEM WITH THAT
LOVELY SCENARIO THEY PAINTED,
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE TO INDICATE
THAT TRUMP IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE RESIGNATION.
DO WE REALLY WANT TO DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI WHO WAS SO
AFRAID THAT HE HAS TO RESIGN IF
HE IS TOTALLY IN THE RIGHT?
OF COURSE WE DON'T.
WHITE HOUSE SPOKESWOMAN SARAH
HUCKABEE SANDERS SAID THIS.
>> CAN YOU SAY DEFINITIVELY THAT
THE PRESIDENT DID NOT PLAY A
ROLE IN HIM STEPPING DOWN?
>> YES.
>> Laura: ARE MORE LIKELY
THEORY, I THINK, IS THAT
McCABE HIMSELF, ALONG WITH HIS
PREVIOUS BOSS, JIM COMEY, ARE
ACTUALLY TO BLAME FOR THIS EARLY
RETIREMENT.
GIVEN McCABE, HE AND HIS WIFE
TO HILLARY'S BEST FRIEND TERRY
McAULIFFE, HE SHOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN WITHIN 100 YARDS OF EITHER
NOT WITH THAT CLOSE TIE.
HIS WIFE RECEIVED A $500,000
DONATION FROM TERRY McAULIFFE
PAC FROM HER POLITICAL CAMPAIGN.
GIVEN THIS, HE SHOULD HAVE
REMOVED HIMSELF OR REMOVED
NOMADIC RECUSED HIMSELF FROM
BOTH PROBES.
THERE WAS A "NEW YORK TIMES"
STORY TONIGHT SUGGESTING THAT
FBI DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER WRAY
WAS CONCERNED ABOUT THE FINDINGS
OF A FORTHCOMING GOVERNMENT
INVESTIGATION INTO THE FBI AND
INTO McCABE'S CONDUCT.
THAT'S THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
REPORT.
THE TIME SOURCE SAID THAT THE
DIRECTOR AND McCABE HAD A
FRANK CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT
REPORT AND APPARENTLY A DEMOTION
WAS DISCUSSED FOR McCABE.
WHATEVER THE EXPLANATION FOR HIS
THE PRESIDENT IS ACTUALLY TRYING
TO RESTORE CONFIDENCE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT INSTITUTIONS THAT I
THINK FOR A LONG TIME HAVE BEEN
USED AS POLITICAL INSTRUMENTS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF GREAT
RANK-AND-FILE PEOPLE, AT THE AT
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY.
BUT WHEN THE LEADERSHIP APPEARS
TO HAVE A POLITICAL AX TO GRIND,
NOBODY IS SERVED BY THAT.
AND THE FBI OF ALL PARTISANSHIP.
IT'S CRITICAL.
SESSIONS' DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN
MAY BE THE NEXT ONE ON THE
CHOPPING BLOCK.
HE REPORTEDLY REVIEWED AND
APPROVED THAT FISA APPLICATION
TO SURVEILLED THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, AND WE UNDERSTAND IT
LOOKS LIKE IT WAS BASED ON THAT
OF COURSE THE ANTI-TRUMP ARTISAN
JEANNIE REID AND ANDREW
WEISSMANN SHOULD BE IMMEDIATELY
TERMINATED FROM THE
INVESTIGATION AS WELL BEFORE ANY